let's go next to our caller from the 2:8
one area code who's calling today from
two at one yes and what's going on well
I'm in a pickle call from my brother he
said that if she hits the fan he's going
to get five over and then take me to our
family bunker square they have
apparently like three years worth of
food stored up and basically my whole
family is convinced to the world's about
that okay and I want to know do you have
a doomsday plan and is it even worth it
to form a doomsday plan okay good so
just so I understand Sam is your family
of a particular religious faith oh yeah
this year everybody insist it's fire but
also the ones who are the ones who are
most into prepping or not actually
religious but I do come from a Catholic
family oh okay all right that's
interesting and then we're we're in the
country is this all happening so my
family lives in South Dakota
they are the bunkers apparently in
Montana and I live in Texas and did you
not you you knew about the existence of
this bunker right or was the news of it
also knew oh he was news once I got that
phone calls yeah oh you didn't even know
your family had this bunker I know I do
not know so I've learned a lot of things
in a few days and they're apparently
like getting it ready
why so listen here's my view I do
believe it makes sense to have to do
basic preparedness and we've interviewed
a couple of preparedness experts and
their view tends to be it doesn't really
make sense to plan for the events that
sort of have never happened and aren't
like in the reasonable scope of what
what you can kind of plan for it makes
sense to plan for more likely things so
you can't leave your house at all for
three days or the food supply is
interrupted for a couple of weeks or
something like that so from everything
I've read the the most reasonable thing
to do is to have some some amount of
first aid supplies certainly
non-perishable food that would last a
couple of weeks in a stock that you're
not regularly using you know to feed
yourself and you know certainly now
people are thinking it makes
to have some masks some n95 masks when
when this is all done I'm sure there
will be a lot of people they're gonna do
basic preparedness but you know saying
everyone should have a Montana bunker
with three years of food I mean first of
all it's laughably unaffordable for the
vast majority of the country number one
now that's not a reason not to do it but
it seems from the survival experts I've
spoken to that that's probably more than
what really is logical are you are you
telling me that amassing like 40 guns
and like 30 gallons of Rights and
sticking it in a hole out in the middle
of nowhere is not it's not like a
logical thing that may not be the most
logical thing I've ever heard of right
but but I don't deny I mean no listen
it's completely true like so about a
year and a half ago I did some disaster
preparedness and I I have kits that are
in both of both of the cars that my
girlfriend that I have and then we've
got some supplies at home and then we've
built up kind of our non perishables in
a very very reasonable way and I think
that a lot more people are going to be
doing that and I mean listen I'm keeping
a list of things that once things settle
down if I survive all of this I want to
have just to feel it so like for example
now that we know about the run on masks
okay maybe I'll get twenty masks or you
know fifty masks or some number and have
them for whenever just so I don't have
to worry about it right I put it out of
my head so to speak or whatever I think
that we're gonna see more people
certainly do that once this all settles
down
yeah and that's certainly the smart
thing and so I definitely wish you luck
if society does crumble I I hope that
you're able to find the Montana bunker
thank you all right very good email me
the address or the coordinates or
whatever and we will we will keep that
on file thank you so much appreciate the
phone call let me take a quick break
don't hang up because we will be right
back with your phone calls after this